يمينيه دينيه اصوليه هكذا تعرف في اسرائيل
هي السادسه حكومات زعيم حزب الكود بنيامين
نتنياهو والتي تنشد ثقه الكنيست
تمهيدا لذلك قدم رئيس الحكومه المكلف الى
البرلمان اتفاقياته مع شركائه في الائتلاف
الحكومي
ائتلاف بدا تتضح طبيعته واجدته يكفي انه
يضم في عضويته زعيم حزب عظم يهوديه
الذي صدق الكنيست على توسيع صلاحيته كوزير
للامن القومي في الحكومه المقبله
ده كواحد من تعديلات قانونيه تمكن نتنياهو
من توقيع الاتفاقيات الائتلافيه مع شركائه
من الاحزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه
فمثلا جرى تعديل قانون الحكومه لتعيين
نواب اودين جنائيه في مناصبها وزاريه كما
يسمح تشريع اخر تم اقراره لحزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه المؤيده للاستيطان لتولي منصب
وزير ثاني في وزاره الدفاع
هكذا يخطئ نتنياهو اخر خطوات عودته
السياسيه على راس واحده من اكثر الحكومات
يمنيه في تاريخ اسرائيل وكمان لا يطيق
صبرا يستبق التنصيب بتعهده ان يضع توسيع
الاستيطان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
على راسي اولوياته حكومته يقول ان حكومته
ستعمل على تعزيز وتطوير الاستيطان في جميع
انحاء ما سماها ارض اسرائيل في الجليل
والنقابي والجولان وظيفه الغربيه
ويضيف بان هذا حق حصري للشعب اليهودي
وفق تعميره يؤكد كلامه مخاوف محليه ودوليه
من ازدياد وتيره الاستيطان في ظلمه
تضم احزاب المتشدده مثل العظمه اليهوديه
بزعامه اثمار بنج فير والصهيونيات الدينيه
بقياده بيت اسرائيل سموترش وشاس برئاسه
اريادرعي لا يروق الامر لكثير من
الاسرائيليين يحذر رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه
ولايته
الاسرائيليين من حكومه نتنياهو التي قال
انها خطيره ومتطرفه وان رئيسها ضعيف وفقد
سيطره عليها حتى قبل تنصيبها
[موسيقى]
غيره من قاده المعارضه المستقبليه
يتعاهدون بالعمل ضد حكومه يخشون انها قد
تحاول اسرائيل الى دوله دينيه ثم تقلق
تثيره تركيبه الحكومه في واشنطن بسبب
المواقف المتطرفه لعدد من اعضائها قاده
يهود امريكيون ابدو مخاوف من ان تلك
النزعه العنصريه ستعرقل دعم جاليتهم
لاسرائيل بشكل خطير